c'est un habitant de la commune de
l'achat yeuse qui a prévenu les secours
hier soir vers 17 heures lorsque cette
personne a indiqué par téléphone avoir
entendu des bruits de moteurs
dysfonctionnements puis un autre comme
une grosse explosion dans les environs
du site de saint laurent la roche vers
18 heures c'est donc un gros dispositif
qui a été déployé ici dans cette partie
très boisée du revermont
un dispositif destiné à retrouver un
petit avion bimoteur qui avait disparu
des écrans radar dans la fin de l'après
midi
c'est cet avion qui a donc été retrouvé
cette nuit grâce aux recherches rendu
très difficile par le relief escarpé la
forêt très dense sur ces monts jurassien
à l'heure où je vous parle tout le
secteur de l'accident est circonscrit et
protégé par la gendarmerie pour empêcher
toute personne d'approcher des débris de
l'appareil
selon nos premières informations l'avion
en portait un couple avec un enfant à
bord un couple parti de paris pour la
région d'annemasse